never have I ever sent a nude hello
welcome to never have I ever it's a game
where we put up five fingers and we say
things that we have never done but that
we think other people have done and we
try to get them to put down all their
fingers last one standing wins the game
you played ladies I always get out first
because I've done everything almost
never have I ever gotten first I got no
yes start never have I ever shut my
pants like like trusted a role fart
basically I mean we're all babysitter's
yeah like like an adult change okay you
really have done everything I think I
drank a lot one night and then the next
morning I kind of had the little Lucy
stools night
I ate like King Taco your shoes yeah oh
one time in JK news I ain't King Taco
and had a Red Bull like I didn't like
people myself but I could have but I
felt like you could I could I didn't get
in that moment I knew I had the ability
to [ __ ] on myself just a little like a
little drop yeah just always the one
that's like I got the bubble guts but I
never have I ever had a threesome [ __ ]
we both wanted to ran ran ran ran we
were very clean very very Deena act like
it was the most delicate sex of her life
butterflies came out never have I ever
doosh my butthole I think you're the
only one that shut their pants like
maybe you should've there's not a lot
but I haven't done I have to dig really
deep guys usually yeah okay this is
count if I use a bidet is what you get
out first cuz you're supposed to say
things you think other people have done
I've done never have I ever gone to a
rave my best friends were candy kids
when I'm we were like 13 14 they were
obsessed with party monster and it was
not about you though whoa no it's just
not my scene okay okay cuz all the goth
kids at my school were also into raves I
never won no I bite 16 I was an
Abercrombie kids oh yeah yeah never have
I ever slept with a stuffed animal as an
adult damn it okay cuz here's the thing
is I had a stitch stuffed animal on my
bed as an adult but I would take him off
to go to bed so I left with my really
good nose like as a pillow
sorry book
but Nikki and I learned that we don't
know each other did learn about each
other tonight bows don't do raves
I don't do stuffed animal okay surprise
surprise I don't go to bed in these it's
bedtime my bed okay okay
Dina never have I ever had an emo seen
face Punk yo-yos not an emo face what's
the difference gutter Punk is way
different from an emo kid I will [ __ ]
kill an emo kid when I was in high
school was like emo kids are [ __ ]
lame I'm gonna gutter Punk them into the
ground
oh dude I was like into hardcore punk
metal emo like I just did all of it no
emo is very specific you just say oh
those big all right right in my hair dad
do I get my thumb back know you we saw
you you were - I know I'm talking like
British [ __ ] no effect we're talking
about SID British garnish cutter closer
you had a creepy age GBH look that's
real Punk oh my god write about it and
write about under zynga yeah
we're on our tumblr never have I ever
lived in a beach town oh I didn't mean
to get you out I mean I know you didn't
live in a beach them but won't be stones
whoa you're up on an island yeah look it
up Mustang island oh that's a horse
sounding island I've ever heard of my
life two guns go on the trees guns grow
my trees I grew up in Santa Barbara a
literal beach town never have I ever
worked in Beverly Hills does that count
as like filming on set and [ __ ] in
Beverly Hills that's word like a day job
or is it like were you worried work they
worked that day no the other kind of
mint and I was like an actual job but no
she worked she worked make money never
have I ever gotten a tattoo I'm catching
up
oh okay never have I ever dated somebody
with 150 thousand Instagram followers I
think Steve has like 40 he's got 85 oh
right now lady my thing is that I've
never dated anyone that was like
Instagram or Internet popular we were
dating four years ago he knows 20,000
you're gonna get attacked in the
comments you better put that finger down
you know what I meant I gave him those
you know what I mean they know what I
meant
put him down tell y'all telling put him
down you chief I just pulled up my ex
those like how you [ __ ] yeah
never have I ever sent a nude I've only
sent like me in lingerie and [ __ ] but
not new do but picture I've never sent a
picture of my breasts or regime nobody
titties
alright no one got the Tippie titties
dude there's literally post on this
website called and on I be like
literally from when I was high school
people saying anyone got anything boys
where's [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm sure people
have posted about you guys because
people can hack that [ __ ] shop it but
it's on know that if you've ever seen a
nude of nice rig you know actually this
was funny so I I told you guys how I met
up with my best friend for the first
time in years 15 years I've known that I
post about this a while back I've known
this girl since we were like 12 like 11
12 and when we met up she told me she
was like oh a lot of this stuff that he
told me when we were younger really
resonated I was like like what and she
was like well one time you called me and
you were like daelin never ever ever
send a guy in nude never ever ever do it
and I was like did I she was again I was
like sounds like me like God has been
like my principal since I was very very
young same yeah I've always been very
afraid oh whatever I'm [ __ ] when I was
four like 14 or 15 I was dating an older
guy and one time my mom's gonna hear
about this oh my god you guys are gonna
hear about this - oh my god you guys
already heard about it when I was like
14 no 15 I dated an older guy he was
like 18 or 19 and I took pictures in
like lingerie like a bra and underwear
and I took him on I didn't have a can of
phone at the time I had like a regular
camera so I had to plug them to the USB
and upload them to my computer my mom
found them and I never felt so much
shame in my entire life I felt so much
shame and I just never took a picture
after that like I just I can't do it she
beat the [ __ ] out no she just like she's
just very Christian and she made like
she she was sad she was so sad and like
I just felt that on another level I
can't do it
yeah this really is bumpy this bummer
what hot tip don't don't put our face in
it don't put your faith in and don't let
Rahman fight I mean look we are here
teaching the brothels tell me who's got
some [ __ ] it just just see what happens
Boyd wouldn't like it goes like a
celebrity shot never have I ever heard
or seen my parents have sex
oh I would be out again oh yeah I've
seen both you didn't know you're out by
I don't want to know nobody's your ghost
gene I would say celebrity shot County I
just wanted to know that's all
you poor thing yeah I'm not gonna beat
these fools never have I ever done
anything to process my hair in the past
ten years
[Applause]
relaxer I was like [ __ ] I'm a buckets
both of you because I don't know if you
dyed it I really think about this this
is hard it is obviously this one ball
I'm gonna take you guys both out very
easily unfortunately I will come out as
the winner satisfied with this leg I
want nothing more I want something more
you know you went out with us you could
go out there you go hey wait what do you
me to do never I've ever gotten married
but that's not what I was gonna do
[Applause]
hi I'm the purest emerge and shiny one
finger I'll have sex before marry me
relationship [ __ ] for after sex I
like Nikki's definition of living life
is being thrown into an end table while
having sex large missionary position sex
with Mickey sock into a situation like
this you say it's cool and look at these
socks our Vegas never have I ever found
a family member attractive what the [ __ ]
oh maybe something L from Alabama I
don't know no [ __ ] it objectively say
you don't think your dad's kind of
handsome I'm like Louise so you just
said objectively attractive don't really
date why should never have I ever been
part of a special forum online moderator
I was my I was an active user on jazzy
boards there's a graphic design board
for teams I know that I never knew pic
[ __ ] you did you know you didn't I
expected you to learn HTML from
transferred making the M&M board look
better I learned it cuz of my face
Oh true I learned it for my face in my
Sangha never have I ever
memorize the lyrics to an eminence come
on by Nicky never have I ever dated an
asian guy really I'm gonna [ __ ] do
damn just give us all I was thinking
about about that but for a different
ethnicity me too
and I was like let me not put myself in
I love me some Taiwanese guys yeah never
have I ever been sober for more than 60
days after the age of 21 I take it back
thirty days so that means if I have okay
yeah I've been sober a lot for like the
whole time I was in my last relationship
I'm confused
never have I ever been sober for more
than 30 days after turning 21 straight
or more yeah so that's just kind of
disparaging to you like how is this like
throwing us under the bus
no because you always all have to put a
finger down she's just saying like I've
had a drink like at least every couple
weeks like wait this isn't how you play
this game yeah yeah I worked at bars
cocktail sir I didn't really start
drinking until like this year yeah I
know I know
loser here we go here we go double
elimination never I've ever had more
than one cat oh you thought about it I
thought about it but I did it not fair I
love them too there's a really cute
picture of them ain't no worries it'd be
worth losing for
for you okay never have I ever run a
talent agency boyfriend is you're
running tality damn you could have won
Jess yeah could have had it never have I
ever had sex on a sectional and when I
am I'm like please take me to bed I'm
sorry never I've had sex on a down
comforter down couch down cow that can
what the apartment down in our step came
with the apartment a nice apartment okay
I think with two rounds I have proven
that I am the purest it for the
sleepover
oh right when joy did I'm glad no one
got possessed tonight yet yeah I praise
the Lord and so I'm safe dude I want I
like we guys we stayed in an air B&B
like we have this giant apartment super
beautiful we should have given them like
a little tour of the place because it's
really nice but now I wanna get well
check our blog channels for that
youtube.com slash Nicki you'll be able
to see all the actual apartment though
like I want a house like I want to fake
know we should have a big mood I want a
big mood house we can afford that right
now a big mood apartment
studio with a kitchenette keep watching
him by our merch so that we can get a
big mood apartment a George S will
finance it for us we'll send her out
into the force be sure to LIKE this
video if you like it really helps her
channel out also subscribe so you don't
miss any more content and we will see
you next time morning oh yeah the phone